ya sabemos un poco sobre números
imaginarios y su unidad imaginaria y ajá
así que intentemos ver si podemos
simplificar este tipo de expresiones
tenemos 2 + 3 y 7 y al cuadrado más 5 y
al cubo más 9 y a la cuarta potencia y
de hecho intenta ver si puedes tú
simplificar esto pone pausa el vídeo
inténtalo
de hecho como puedes ver aquí tenemos
ahí elevado la primera potencia es
cierto ahora acá 7 y al cuadrado y
elevado a la segunda potencia esto es
igual a menos 1 esto es igual a menos 1
ahora y elevado a la tercera potencia y
al cubo es igual a esto multiplicado por
y entonces menos y ahora vamos con la
siguiente potencia que es la cuarta y
elevado a la cuarta potencia es igual a
y que multiplica a esto lo cual es lo
mismo que menos uno por y menos uno por
y esto ya llegamos al cubo cierto ahora
por y entonces y por y es igual a menos
uno por menos uno lo cual es igual a uno
entonces podemos reescribir todo esto de
la siguiente manera esto
presión se reduce a dos más tres por y
más siete día al cuadrado y al cuadrado
sabemos que es igual a menos uno aquí
está y al cuadrado es igual a menos uno
por lo tanto esto es menos uno tenemos
menos siete menos siete ahora más cinco
y al cubo y al cubo es igual a menos y
por lo tanto esto se va esto se vuelve
menos y así que nos queda menos cinco
por y menos cinco por y ahora finalmente
tenemos la última la última expresión 9
y a la cuarta potencia y a la cuarta
potencia es igual a 1 entonces esto
simplemente queda como más 9 ahora bien
cómo podemos simplificar esto más
tenemos aquí varios términos que no
tienen unidad imaginaria por lo tanto
son números reales cierto por ejemplo
tenemos aquí a este dos estados es un
número real este 7 negativo es un número
real este 9 también es un número real
así que vamos a sumar estos tres números
reales tenemos 2
7 negativo es igual a 5 negativo y 5
negativo más 9 es igual a 4
estos tres números esos tres números
reales suman 4 en total ahora estos
números con unidad imaginaria tenemos 3
y menos 5 y eso a cuánto es igual si
tienes 3 de algo y le quita 5 de ese
mismo algo entonces te va a quedar menos
2 de algo cierto otra manera de pensar
en esto sería solamente de los números 3
menos 5 es igual a menos 2 así que tres
y menos 5 y es igual a menos 2 y menos
dos y así que este es el resultado final
lo podemos simplificar más no de hecho
no podemos hacerlo porque porque este 4
es un número real mientras que este 2
este menos 2 y es un número imaginario
este este menos 2 y es un número
imaginario así que el resultado final es
4 - 2 y ahora podemos considerar a toda
esta expresión como un número
ajá este es un número que tiene una
parte real y una parte imaginaria en
números de este estilo de este estilo se
llaman o son llamados números complejos
estos son los números complejos números
complejos ahora porque se le llama
complejo bueno porque tiene una parte
real y una parte imaginaria es cierto y
tal vez tú pienses o perfecto ok ahora
acaso no es posible que cualquier número
real sea considerado un número complejo
por ejemplo si tenemos al número real el
número real 3 lo puede escribir de la
forma 30 y 30 y esto esto es correcto de
hecho un todo número todo número real de
emociones todo números reales un número
complejo ajá los números reales son un
subconjunto de los números complejos de
igual manera los números imaginarios son
un subconjunto de los números complejos
por ejemplo tú puedes escribir ahí como
como un 0 que es una parte real
0 + y baja por lo tanto los números
imaginarios son un subconjunto de los
números complejos y los números reales
también son un subconjunto de los
números complejos los números complejos
tienen una suma de esta combinación
reales e imaginarios